it's colton wong set to lead things off
long smokes one deep into right field
and it's one nothing brew crew that's
how you start your saturday afternoon
well we've seen that before with colton
wong i mean no better way to start a
game than with colton knocking one out
the brewers bats were unbelievable at
wrigley field in a four-game sweep
against the cubs
and they come out swinging here today
wow
one two right there on the inner edge
strike three call with a fastball at 94.
wilson strikes out escobar there's a
stake with this early lead courtesy of
the colton wong home run and he gets a
strike out of hoy park to start the
bottom half of the first
promising young players in this pirates
organization and back-to-back strikeouts
here for anderson in the first
swing and a miss he struck him out brett
anderson strikes out the side
here in the bottom of the first inning
this pitch swinging and he shoots one
through and into right field of day's
hit those hands are quick brewers bench
for craig council here this afternoon as
taylor rips one fair and down the line
and to the corner it goes tele is on his
way to third he'll coast it in there a
double for taylor and the brewers in the
second inning are threatening again
double to left and there's a ground ball
with the infield in and now look at this
wow
you'll take it as good as the brewers
are a base running mistake here
bradley jr the runner at first or manny
pina
rice wilson the two strike pigs that
bounce up there it gets away from
stallings here's teles to the plate and
it's two to nothing brewers and now the
throw gets away from wilson moving to
third is jackie bradley jr the viewers
pick up their second run of the day make
it three as penis shoots one into center
field that gets bradley home and its
three-nothing brew crew
and that's back up the middle and the
throw is in plenty of time for route
number one
well talk about impressive there's
rodolfo castro
lacing a ball into center field the 22
year old
switch hitter a two out double
3-0 is a high fly into right
looks like taylor's going to have a play
on it on the warning track in front of
the clemente wall he makes the catch and
the inning is over it's the 1-1 pitch
and here's a line drive into right field
that's down for a base hit for christian
yelich
that's exactly what you're looking for
right there brownie two for one
take that every time 5-4-3
another one this time he gets it with a
little skip by stew
and a double for new
how about that that's called making an
adjustment there's
new minute third with one out hoy park
is coming up the two one from him and a
ball poked towards short rounded by
adamus he'll flip it on the first park
beat it out it's an infield hit and the
run bat of ed newman is across home
plate and it's three to one milwaukee
see we'll get another break here
as hayes beats it out so a couple
infield singles
[Applause]
anderson being very careful to reynolds
and in doing that he walks him i think
milwaukee leads three to one with one
out colin moran coming up here's the
pitch he swings and chops one right at
the bag at first on the backhand telez
touches first throw to the plate late
it's an rbi bounce out and the pirates
now within three to two
and a ground ball diving stop by adamus
what a play oh
telez can't make the pick how about this
wild inning the pirates now lead it four
to three
so here's tyrone who doubled back in the
second inning two old pitch to taylor
coming
and that has hit well into left field
going back is park looking up reaching
out can't get it it's gone
tyrone taylor the solo shot and we are
tied at four
didn't leave by much but it doesn't have
to maybe second row back there and left
can get changed up and taylor barrels it
up
there's a ground ball that beats the
shift
[Applause]
newman puts a charge into one sending
bradley back to the wall and he can't
make the catch
polanco had to hold
it's second and third it's kevin newman
with the last maybe a couple weeks
starting to see him put a charge into
the baseball john nagowski will pinch it
for wilson while the pirate's prescient
they already had him out on deck
and there's a line drive for nagowski a
pinch hit rbi single to give the pirates
the lead
council making a move here's jake
cousins today's gruber law offices one
call that's all cousins lifts the leg
and then puts it down comes to the set
and delivers and swinging a hard liner
up the middle base hit newman is in
easily nagowski advances to second on
the rbi single by key brian hayes the
pirates lead it six to four
and draws the walk
loads them up now for moran cousins with
a one two
and that is bounced over to second
there's one adamus double plan boy was
that big
3-1 pitch
and the brewers had their lead off man
on again that's a way to start the
inning
whoops oh my gosh wow that almost picked
off
adamus
that was close
big strikeout right there
newman two doubles today
one up the line one into the gap
and this in the left field that's what
you're talking about
from hard hits to just playing
and another double his first career
three double game for kevin newman have
a game newman pensioner wilmer defoe
banning for shreve
and this is headed up the middle that's
a seeing eye single and that will score
a run
again as neil walker just said they come
in bunches they come in all varieties
and we're seeing that variety in this
inning
right side
they'll get one that's all they'll get
rbi for hayes pirates have scored 10
runs pirates have collected 14 hits none
by reynolds or moran
and that's a line drive toward the
clemente wall and clear the deck
cannonball coming
and anchor down for brian reynolds a
three-run blast number 21.
give him 70 ribbies
a 12-4 lead here in the fifth inning
aligned to left field newman is he going
to have a four double game
four doubles in four played appearances
for kevin newman
and there's a hit for reynolds
and cora gonna give reynolds two more
ribbies he's gonna wave a second why not
and here is luis oviedo gonna get some
work in
[Applause]
and raise it
raise the jolly roger the pirates with
14 runs 19 hits the most by any team in
a seven inning doubleheader game